because now I can't even dream was
speaking about sleeping knowing Brianna
Taylor's killers have not been arrested
when I said I don't got the time I'm on
my trampoline I lent it cuz give it a
minute and races I'm gonna take the
bounce out of that too that was just one
of the many powerful political moments
delivered by host Amanda seals during
the 2020 Beatty Awards the VP Awards a
little different main thing is it's
virtual we're getting real in touch with
being real inside because outside is all
one it's got Colvin and cops and Karen's
gone wild it's like we hated on 20:19 so
much it called it's brother 2020 to come
through and provide a collective Molly
Wow and that's precisely why we had to
the awards cuz we deserve a break seals
drop the strong words during her opening
monologue something the comedian
promised she would do when et spoke to
her before the show I know your platform
Amanda is also to always amplify black
voices so with everything going on in
the world I know B et is gonna give us
something special but how do you how
does the network and you yourself
address where we are in the state of our
nation right now you know what honestly
it's more seamless than I think people
imagined you know for other networks and
other shows it might require a lot more
thought process but for a black music
show black music has always been
intrinsically connected to what's going
on in black lives so we're seeing
artists who are just very seamlessly and
organically bringing in what's happening
in the world into their performances and
I'm doing the same thing with my comedy
and my hosting so really what we're
gonna do is what exactly is expected of
black folks we're gonna speak and
perform from the natural space where we
are right now as black American
Americans I'm brand new about racism
like dr. Martin Luther King jr. was
doing all them speeches for album
interludes now they talking about
Juneteenth it's dope but y'all don't let
them Cinco DeMayo our day if we ain't
watchful every June 19th folks gonna be
at the bar where Frederick Douglass wig
hats order and Harriet teenies off the
drink special I always know where your
head is and I always love to listen to
your respect
but where's how's your heart where's
your heart right now a lot of people
just like out of our you know because
I'll be like really excited about
something and happy and then I'll go to
my phone and I'll see another story of
another black person that is dealing
with discrimination in a myriad of ways
from cops to coal did to Karen and
Amanda took on Karen's in this skit
during the show and I was thinking about
a young african-american woman with
those cord things in her hair I think
look how graves well anyways I said
excuse me I think they're just boring in
first class right now and she whipped
around and said don't assume just
because I'm black but I don't belong to
first class folks just want to see
responsibilities taken and actualized
ways it's not just through like you know
it's the grand posts of black squares
and black and white videos of people
looking real serious we want to see some
true measure of a commitment to
understanding that discrimination has
been at a core has been a core piece of
the advancement of all these other
groups and still when we look at
Hollywood like you can't shy away from
the fact that like a prejudice and
discrimination racism they are built
into the threads of this town the
conversations that are being had are
about actualized change and it's it's
got to go beyond just having the
conversations with your black friends
it's got to go beyond just being like no
I'm the cool one it's like there has to
be an actual visual verbal and action
based response and you know and we're
all doing that I donate protest vote
speak we are each other's business when
we look out for each other we lift each
other up
Brianna Taylor's killers are still
walking free
goodnight show
[Music]